[Applause]
imagine if your bank accounts were
frozen without warning
[Music]
where you've been paying for an
apartment that hasn't been built that's
happening in china where economic woes
have pushed people to the streets
and some people online like homeowners
who were threatening to stop paying
their mortgages until developers clear
construction delays and hand over the
homes they bought
china's gdp growth was close to zero
during the second quarter amid coveted
lockdowns and supply chain issues
these protests highlight specific
troubles and parts of china's economy so
here's what's happening and how the
authorities are trying to keep things
under control
[Music]
in china there's been no room for
political protests to challenge the
leadership just look at beijing's
suppression of hong kong's pro-democracy
movement since 2019.
but the protests this summer are
different this
shows the recent pattern mass protests
in china because people have immediate
issues
to address that really affect themselves
directly tai chi is an associate
professor who's been studying social
activism in china for 20 years he says
protesters can't target the ruling
communist party if they want to be heard
if you have playful demands there's no
room for negotiation but the scenarios
we have seen are different they're not
political they're economic or financial
interest driven
one major issue has been the country's
real estate sector collectively urban
chinese have nearly 78 of their well
tied up in residential property and many
have yet to see their new homes because
developers don't have enough money to
finish building apartments they've
pre-sold to get a sense of how
homeowners have been left waiting in
limbo take a look at this chart the blue
line shows the number of housing
projects that started construction in
2021. the red line is the number of
projects that have been completed there
are few reasons for this first the
government's strict limits on property
developers leverage caused some of them
to default on their debt
and on top of that the slowing economy
and covid lockdowns that triggered a
drop in home sales which fell nearly 40
in july compared to last year as a
result many developers have had less
cash to fund construction
so frustrated buyers of unfinished homes
have joined a movement that's been
gathering steam on chinese social media
these are hundreds of joint letters
issued by homeowners from more than 100
cities across the country they've been
circulating online and all of them share
a similar message that they'll stop
their mortgage payments until developers
finish and hand over the apartments the
mortgage revolt left authorities
scrambling to reassure home buyers that
projects will be completed some local
governments rolled out tax rebates cash
rewards and lower down payments to boost
their property markets the tradition
of chinese protest
you have to make a very loud voice to
get hurt
another problem that's triggered loud
complaints thanks in the city of
zhengzhou protesters vented their anger
at rural lenders for freezing their
accounts this comes amid a government
investigation into financial misconduct
by a private investment group their
immediate appeals to get their money
back they're not asking
anything more than that
chaos erupted when a group of
unidentified men in white t-shirts
rammed into the crowd the wall street
journal couldn't determine their
identity and neither the bank nor the
local government responded to requests
for comment the incident went viral on
chinese social media and got the
attention of the authorities that's when
local officials stepped in and made
concessions to appease demonstrators
with two rounds of repayments to
depositors they are giving indications
that the government is working on those
issues that's the typical strategy
for china's leaders maintaining
stability is a top economic priority so
to stop the protest from growing the
country's top policy-making body said it
would work to resolve problems in the
rural banking system and it told local
governments to take direct
responsibility for delivering unfinished
homes and supporting demand for housing
so without finding ways to keep the
economy going more problems will show up
this may be the opportunity for them to
figure out what's the best way to move
forward and also to find ways
international economic policy to solve
these issues
stability is also the back to our
president xi jinping needs as he tries
to secure a precedent breaking third
term in a few months
[Music]